if you enjoy short stories philosophy
reading or of course all of the above
consider checking out my books I
published both fiction and non-fiction
and if you enjoy pursuit of Wonder
content I think you'll really enjoy my
books as well the link to them is in the
description it's been 29 years since we
left things were going well for a while
mostly the plan not that we had much of
a plan we just needed to get out of
there survive explore find somewhere to
call home I'm not entirely sure at this
point for a while we were just floating
still in a semiconscious state mostly
unaware of our surroundings we
communicated to each other via brain
signals transmitted out into space and
across the network of stasis pod ships
moving aimlessly through space is not so
bad when you're barely conscious and
you're not yet worried about arriving
anywhere a lot has changed since then
system failures cosmic ray damage
navigation interference the inherent
consequences of a lapse time in a
chaotic universe
our beta adrenergic blocking agents and
Gamma hydroxy berate Supply was supposed
to last much longer at least that's what
we thought it began to wear off not too
long into The Journey though pretty soon
we were only left with each other to
keep ourselves sane through our bmis in
the ship's Cloud Network we transmitted
out and shared our dreams our fears our
jokes our sources of joy and hope but
things continue to go wrong as we
drifted further through space we also
drifted further apart from each other
the slightest differences in our initial
launch conditions increasingly affected
our individual trajectories over time
sending each ship further and further in
its own Direction many of us including
myself tried to override the ship system
controls in order to open our stasis pod
and access the manual navigation panel
but the system wouldn't allow it
possibly some sort of system failure or
maybe it's just a system doing its job
sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference soon what was once a crew of
many became many crws a few we can't
communicate much anymore with those who
have drifted further away occasionally
we'll intercept a signal scattered
thoughts and updates masted in static in
obscurity they're increasingly fewer and
farther between for a while I tried to
fill in the blanks between signals but
pretty soon I mostly just gave up on
that individuals that are no longer in
range might as well be dead to me I fear
some of them might actually be even many
of the remaining closer ships have
spread out a good distance now it takes
us significant amount of energy to
transmit and receive signals with them
staticy and nonlinear signals greatly
limit the depth and Clarity of
communication at a certain point it
feels like there's not even much to
transmit to or receive from them anymore
the same weak signals and updates over
and over don't provide much for
anyone I'd be lying if I didn't say the
empty space didn't feel constricting
it's funny how nothing can be so
uncomfortable as more time has passed
and the Lucidity of my Consciousness has
returned more to me the the less hopeful
I've become that we'll ever find a
destination out here we were all just
floating on our own trajectories to
Nowhere initially the goal was to arrive
somewhere but I think I've realized in
the aimless chaos of space that it's
better to know how to adapt than to
plan I remember before we left when I
used to sit on my balcony and stare up
at the stars I remember fantasizing
about being up there up here
experiencing and journeying through the
unknown now I am here and this is how I
feel this is the best I can
do there are still a couple of ships in
functional signal range with me it's
been kind of nice actually having just a
couple less signals makes it easier to
just focus on the close ones most
recently one ship in particular has been
especially in full clear consistent
signal range and that one ship that one
signal feed has provided more to me than
what the total network of hundreds of
other ships had previously it's almost
as if it's it's just our journey now
signal strength is still far from
perfect it never was though some things
nothing can communicate but to share
this vast emptiness of space with
another individual as deeply as you can
I've never felt anything so
full perhaps aimlessness is as good of a
destination as any if I'm ever going to
arrive anywhere maybe I should start
here there was nothing out here for us
there never was but now there is us out
here
I hope the other ships that are still
close will stay close I hope that in the
distant future perhaps my path will
reconvene with those who have drifted
further apart and I hope the closest one
will remain the closest one but I can't
control the cosmos I can't control other
ships I can't even control mine we're
all subject to the cosmic forces that be
but until I drift further away or until
all the others do I'm going to try to be
happy or at least okay that I get to be
here that I get to Journey Through the
stars and that I get to share this even
if from afar with anyone at
all it will all be over
soon if you enjoyed this video and want
to help support pursuit of Wonder and my
work in general again consider checking
out my books I have a new novela out
called the closer we get which is a
story that explores the complexities of
love and the future of human connection
or if you prefer non-fiction you could
check out The Art of Living a
meaningless existence which contains my
collected works that journey through
philosophy and grapple with the
increasingly relevant problem of finding
meaning in what appears for many of us
to be an inherently meaningless
existence the links for them are in the
description and of course as always
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next
video